for obvious reasons I hope when you eat
animals you are causing them harm not
only are you causing the animals harm
which goes against the precept of ahimsa
but you're causing harm to the
environment ultimately you're causing
harm to yourself and other human beings
under a false impression that you're
gaining something for yourself but the
age-old wisdom is that nothing of
benefit can ever come to you by causing
harm to someone else it just doesn't
work that way
whatever we do will eventually but
inevitably come back to us I mean you
don't have to even believe in you know
karma if we looked at this practice of
eating animals and robbing them of their
fluids their milk their eggs we would
see in that practice the actual root
causes of so many of the things in this
world today that we're trying to find
solutions for war poverty global warming
you know the UN issued a statement not
too long ago saying that the waste
emissions from animals used for confined
animals enslaved animals used for food
contributes more to global warming than
all the car and truck emissions in the
world that's significant it's a
significant thing to look at but we're
so conditioned and it's to eat meat and
to drink milk that it
it's a physiological addiction that even
though we may think that we may have an
idea in our head that it might be better
to be a vegetarian we have the bodies of
of an addicts and so we'll have to deal
with that which is like it's huge but it
can be done it can be done in fact I say
vegetarianism but I really mean
vegetarianism meaning only eat a
plant-based diet which of course there's
a word for that these days it's called
vegan and that's what I really mean but
sometimes that word is very scary to
people so vegetarianism seems more soft
or sometimes when you say vegetarianism
people think that it's okay to eat fish
or drink milk and well not if you want
to enhance this planet not if you want
to be happy not if you want to
contribute to a better world you know
just the United States we kill 10,000 to
attend God ten billion land animals
every year for food ten billion there
are only six billion human beings on the
entire planet so this is just in the
United States we're killing 10 billion
land animals those are the animals that
are in the factory farms not even I'm
not even counting the animals that are
the wild animals that are hunted just
that confined enslaved animals but we're
killing many more sea creatures and the
statistics for individual sea creatures
are very hard there it's estimated 17
billion sea creatures but usually sea
creatures are measured in tonnage and
the statistic for for that is 80 million
tons of fish
and sea creatures 80 million tons every
year this is just United States
statistics and one third of that is
bycatch meaning you know they're seals
and birds and other animals that are
caught with the big nets and trawlers
that are that are thrown back and but
they're not thrown back and in a healthy
way they're they're dead or dying and 99
percent of them will die now this is
like a huge huge thing that's going on
that most people aren't aware that all
the animals that are in the factory
farms are eating other animals and we
have to remember that those animals in
the factory forms for the most part of
vegetarian animals we as human beings
like to eat vegetarian animals but
they're vegetarian by nature but none of
them absolutely none of them are
vegetarian now because we're force
feeding them fish chickens cows sheep
pigs I mean the FDA assures us that
we're not feeding cows to cows but we're
feeding cows to every other animal in a
factory farm situation you know the
statistic very famous statistic that
John Robbins animal rights activist
author of diet for a new America put
forth in Maine in the mainstream was
that it takes 12 pounds of grain to make
one pound of beef and his argument was
that grain could be used to feed hungry
human beings instead of being fed too
to animals well it may take 12 pounds of
grain to make one pound of beef but you
know it takes a hundred pounds of fish
to make one pound of beef those animals
and factory farms are all children we
fatten them up so quickly with
genetically we genetically engineer them
so that they grow very quickly we give
them the antibiotics and so they're
basically slaughtered when they're when
they're babies so we're eating children
we're eating children that's perverted
and then the dairy and people think well
the dairy cows what's wrong with
drinking milk that's like that's not
hurting a cow cows are meant to be
milked aren't they I get that question a
lot well a cow like like any other
mammal gives milk when she's pregnant or
when she just had a baby and the dairy
cows really perhaps have the worst life
of a confined animal I think in factory
farms and if we're if we're really
wanting freedom and equality for women
if we really consider ourselves
feminists then we gotta stop drinking
milk and eating eggs because that is a
crime against females that practice
because those animals are enslaved
because they are women because they can
give milk because they can give birth to
babies because they do produce eggs so
the dairy cow is chained to a stall for
the whole of her life raped by a human
being you know with a artificial
insemination 'less steal like a turkey
baster sort of thing continuously raped
um chained to the stall she's
impregnated she carries the baby while
she's chained meanwhile she's being
milked several times a day by machines
she gives birth to the baby who's taken
away from her
within hours within hours and then she's
impregnated again almost immediately and
the whole cycle happens again and again
well she can't really stand who could
stand this for very long and so she
basically dies from exhaustion within
about three or four years dairy cows are
slaughtered at three to four years old
their children once again a a cow who's
able to live out and so according normal
type of life will live to be 25 or 30
years old our practice of eating animals
our practice of drinking the milk from
animals has to be has to be questioned
if we if we want to build a better world
now I'm not gonna say that you know the
cause of all the the evil within the
world today the cause of why human
beings are acting the way that we're
acting is because we're treating animals
so badly but I will say that that is a
very primary cause
you